[Music]
now to scotland
in this week's cover piece the
spectator's editor fraser nelson wonders
whether sturgeon really wants to have a
second referendum now despite what she
might say publicly
to discuss i'm joined now by fraser as
well as our political editor james
forsythe
fraser in this week's cover piece you
say that unionists are actually in a
pretty good position
but if we look at that result the s p
are just one short of a majority
so why is that
well the s p is very good at telling
stories and the story
nicholas sturgeon has got for the world
right now is that scotland is a kind of
country straining at the leash
of the union all set to have another
referendum and if you hear the language
the snp is using now that
they were complaining that there wasn't
a referendum bill in the queen's speech
for example that would set the
legislation
for the next year but if you actually
then rewind and say on what basis
is nicholas sturgeon making this point
the opinion polls show that independence
while a bit more popular last autumn has
now gone back to the kind of support
that we've seen
in 2014 referendum about 44
of scots would like to leave the uk and
also
sturgeon herself the s p won fewer seats
than it did
10 years ago so we've seen that kind of
decade of stagnation
in snp support now she told us that
brexit
would mean that people would be all set
to to leave the uk well
that hasn't happened the brexit vote
hasn't helped the s p vote at all
boris johnson supposedly hated in
scotland doesn't seem to have had much
of a negative impact the scottish tories
and got the same vote share as they did
last in the last scottish election
so we've seen the snp with a lot of
things that should move
down from them simply haven't so nicolas
sturgeon is engaged
in this rather ingenious game of bluff
wanting to tell england and the rest of
the world
that scotland is ready to go in fact the
battle she has got is not with boris
johnson
it's with the half of scots who are by
no means persuaded
that what she says is making much sense
james i think if we look at the snp
result
uh nicholas sturgeon has phrased the
touch they've been quick to herald it as
a big success for them
even a mandate for indie ref too but is
the party suffering from the fact they
had such high expectations
and made them quite public going into
the fact that to fall short of majority
does look
like a failure yes i think the view
in uh westminster and whitehall is
essentially this which is
the situation in scotland is not great
but it is nowhere near as bad as people
feel it could be last autumn remember
last autumn
independence was regularly ahead in the
polls nicola sturgeon used to tweet out
poll results quite regularly there was a
sense that there was a
a small but definite majority in favor
of independence and the snp looked
almost a lock
for a a majority hollywood which is a
remarkable achievement in a
proportionate system
so the fact that uh the snp fell just
short of an overall majority
and currently more polls show
so majority support for staying in the
union rather than leaving it
is i think creating a certain amount of
encouragement
i also think the uk government has
positioned itself in a more sensible
place i think if you
if you look at if you talk to people
who've conducted focus groups in
scotland recently
they say that they think there are two
sets of politicians who will get
punished by electors right now in a
constitutional question
one is the politician who wants to have
the referendum almost immediately
and the other is the person who says
kind of glibly well you can't have it
for another 50 years
and i think the danger was at the start
of the year is that downing street were
falling into that trap boris johnson was
suggesting that you shouldn't have
another referendum for 40 years
i think now the government is saying
look now is not the time as you recover
from a covert pandemic
nicola sturgeon is having to agree with
that
and i think and you so you are you are
pushing
back the date now i i think it is
certainly the government won't grant a
section
30 order and i think what you will see
over the next
few uh months is the smp trying to kind
of whip up a sense of grievance
to push the numbers supporting
independents up and i mean the crucial
thing is the uk government
turns the cheek nicolas sturgeon wants
lots of arguments about
you know she wants uk ministers saying
we'll see you in the supreme court if
you legislate for a referendum
the uk ministers just need to sidestep
those questions
and fraser i wonder you were talking
about the polls
and how actually from the unionist point
of view things are looking better than
they did
six months ago is there an argument that
the uk government should just call nick
of the surgeons bluffs say
you know what have your independence
referendum we think we can win it and
that way
actually finally perhaps put things to
bed
so this is where i think the tories and
there will be some people who would
think look let's call her bluff
have that referendum let's make the case
for the union let's move the
conversation on
to questions like what currency would an
independent scotland use nicolas
sturgeon claims
that she'd have a scottish currency in
which case who would pay
people's pensions what currency would
those pensions be
paid in there are so many questions that
a referendum campaign would open
but i think would really underline the
power and the beauty
and the point of the union but then
again
you could argue that um the uk should
never
shouldn't be sucked into this
never-ending trap
that they should not be playing the
snp's game by having a referendum
whenever the snp wants one
um personally i'm more i'm more
attracted to giving nicholas jordan the
referendum if she
passes a vote in parliament asking her
for one um
but i'm aware that you know there's
quite a lot of unionists who think that
would be a disaster
and playing straight into her hands
james are you one such unionist
well i i think what you look at the
election results in scotland
and what you cannot see from them i
don't think
is an overwhelming desire to have a
second independence referendum that was
a big part of the snp platform
and uh they didn't get over 50 of the
vote
if you look at the constituency vote
very marginally more people voted for
unionist parties than parties that favor
independence if you look at the list
vote
by an even thinner margin uh people
voted uh more people voted for
pro-independence parties
than uh unionist parties but given that
the most recent referendum
was in 20 the last referendum was in
2014.
uh i really failed to see that there is
a there is any kind of super majority in
favor of independence among the
electorate
that would justify going back on the
once in a generation
sense that that referendum was meant to
be for a generation on the basis that
you
couldn't ask such a divisive and
destabilizing question
you know every other day um so i i don't
see
that these elections actually
particularly strengthen the case for
independence they certainly don't
suggest
that there is you know 60 of a scottish
public that is desperate for a
referendum
um but james what i'd like to know is
if the snp were to vote in parliament
for a referendum
what would your position be say no or
caller bluff
my personal view is that if the scottish
parliament were to vote for a referendum
now based on these election results i
don't think that is a sufficient basis
for a referendum
so james if you're opting for the say no
approach in those circumstances can you
talk us through
well i mean tactically i wouldn't have
the uk government say no
i i would i think it would be much
better to have a private citizen
challenge the uh the law in the court of
session uh the court of session
is uh is a fairly uh conservative of a
small c
court and i think it would be likely to
strike the law down
on the basis of the constitution as a
reserve matter and have you got any
private citizens in mind particularly
i don't but i i fraser says in his piece
and i and this this challenge of what
i'm hearing as well
is that that there is already that kind
of funding in place for that
private legal challenge and and if you
but by some quirk of constitutional law
they did manage to hold the referendum i
think the referendum held in these
circumstances should
he simply boycotted by unionists because
the only basis in which you could hold a
referendum would be
uh without the consent of the uk
government would be on the basis that it
had no legal effect and i think unions
should say look we're not part
we're not participating in a referendum
but it's only taking place because it
has no effect
[Music]
you